[Music]
this man
went vegan for just 12 weeks take a look
at how his body transformed
he stopped eating meat cheese
and anything else that comes from an
animal sticking to just fruits and
veggies he went from being in
average shape to having six pack abs
this is what giving up meat and other
animal based products can do to your
body
and this happened in just three months
but today we're going to be giving you
an even bigger
challenge nom
going vegan for a year
could this diet produce significant
health benefits
or is it all just a fad
this is your body on going vegan
i have a question for you do vegans live
longer
and if so how much longer do they live
0 4 10 or 12 years
think about that and we'll have the
answer for you later in the video but
for now
we're going to have you go vegan for a
year that means no meat
cheese eggs or any other animal based
product
how could this limited diet affect your
body
the first week of your new vegan diet
will leave you feeling
foggy and more tired than usual this is
because your body isn't getting the same
nutrients that you're used to
when you take meat out of your diet you
won't be getting as much
b12 this has been a massive contributor
of making you feel strong and alert
okay you're several weeks into eating
nothing but fruits
vegetables and nuts and you'll notice
that you're becoming more
regular this is due to the increase of
fiber in your diet
but on top of all this you're still
feeling slightly sluggish and tired
no i mean i really feel terrible i
thought this was supposed to make you
feel better
right it's because you're still not
getting any b12
this vitamin is only available in animal
based products
some foods like mushrooms do have some
but it's not nearly as much as
a steak oh man i miss steak
so instead you'll need to add
nutritional yeast to your cooking
not only will it provide you with b12
but
it also adds a nutty flavor to your food
several months into your veganism any
acne you had will start to clear up
and remember to add some vitamin d pills
to your daily habit
without animal based products you've got
a severe lack of vitamin d
which has most likely left you feeling
muscle soreness and cramps
and due to all the vegetables and
non-processed foods you've been eating
you would also see
some inches disappear from your
waistline
after a full year of going vegan and
taking all the necessary vitamins
you'd start feeling great your heart
health would improve
as you'd be eating much fewer high
cholesterol foods
not only that but compared to other
diets you'd have a significantly less
chance of getting cardiovascular
diseases as well as diabetes
going vegan can even improve your gut
health due to all the extra
fiber in your diet if done correctly
by taking the proper vitamins to
supplement what you're missing from meat
going vegan can be extremely beneficial
to your health
not only would you be making yourself
healthier
but you could also contribute to making
the planet healthier
the beef and cattle industry is one of
the main contributors to global
greenhouse gases
so there's a good chance you'd miss a
juicy hamburger
but this challenge of going vegan for a
year could ultimately benefit you
and if you continue to eat like this how
much longer would you live
well according to the mayo clinic with a
plant-based diet
you could live an extra four years but
now
i'm kinda bored of vegetables what about
something
entirely meat based like a hot dog
eating competition
well we'll see what that challenge
brings on another episode of your body
on